michael thank you for doing this i
appreciate it i love it uh i think that
it's um
it's possible that a lot of you here
know michael graves name from some
signature buildings that he was the
architect of
possibly from
some of his consumer products he
designed there's a target collection
he's pretty well known for the the
alessi teapot is one of the iconic
objects that michael is responsible for
but i actually want to start
somewhere else i want to start
slightly obliquely
with the wheelchair and i wonder if you
would talk about
how you ended up in it
and that'll let us get into some of the
work that you're designing for now
sure
um
there
the story goes
and i say story because now it's nine
years old and you've told it a lot i
know and i've told it a lot
but i'll find a new way to tell it
i was fascinated actually earlier by the
earth moving
i'm always horizontal when the earth
moves but
i was
working too hard and
my immune system was down because
i had a
sinus cold that i couldn't
couldn't shake at all
i
went to europe that was in switzerland
and in germany and
finally looking in sights and for new
buildings and
meetings and so on
and i came back to the united states and
i
couldn't go home and go to bed
i felt rotten but i had to come here to
new york
just off the plane
and
i had to give two lectures
the first time i was back in the second
night i was back
so by the time i
got to princeton i was exhausted and
pretty wary and
i slept on sunday and went to
went to clay i went to class went to
the office on monday morning
and for the first time in my life i
couldn't get through the day
that has never happened
and uh
the pain in my back was so intense
and
all the tylenol in the world was not
going to help
so i
took myself to the
to the
hospital and
and
then spent the night there
and the next morning i was
the worst night of my life
i had what is called nerve pain
if you have a
toothache
that's the nerve the thinking
and you know what it's like to have the
drill hit it
well that's what it was like for
all night long
it was one of those nights where you
said no okay i'd rather die you know
it's enough you i can't do this
and so i um
i
uh
i was
urged by people in my office to
get better care because
not to talk down princeton hospital
that's the hospital that's on
on
well it's his house right princeton
plainsboro
no he'd have figured it out
now he would have figured it out but you
know how many meetings in that little
room
or whatever they have had well that's
always going on but they didn't know
and still don't i'll interrupt you i
still don't
but uh the end of the story is that
um
i didn't have surgery
uh the
paralysis stopped
here
so i can't do more than that
which becomes important for other kind
of stories i tell
and
i
was was feeling
in in
rehab i
by this time i had gone to too many
hospitals and to have all kinds of
things tests done
and
and then then finally to rehab
i went to kessler
where
uh christopher reeve went who was also
from princeton
so i thought well if christopher
christopher's done the research this is
probably where i should go
so i went there and
and
i was
i was feeling very strange because i
every morning i would wake up and it was
as as though
both arms were asleep
and i would have to do all kinds of
finger exercises to get going is to have
breakfast
this isn't right
a friend of mine from miami who was a
former student of mine
stopped by
and i told her about this problem and
she said
just because it was on my mind
and she said well you know
in
miami
we have one of the greatest
specialists
and one of the
great
clinics for
spinal cord in jackson memorial hospital
and it's run by a man by the name of
barth green
and you should you should get to know
barth
and
so indeed i
did call him and tell him what was
happening and he said get me an mri
and it was very matter of fact give me
an mri send it to me i'll let you know
i i did that
and he called back and he said
get on the next plane to miami
and he operated for nine or ten hours
and he told
the interview of
interviewer of
sunday morning cbs sunday morning that i
was
drowning from the inside out i've never
understood that so
don't ask but you you said
i think this is the new york times when
you were at kessler in rehab you had
this quote and i know it's been retold
since you said i can't die here it's too
ugly
but there was
i was a kessler um
i don't mean to talk smack about kessler
necessarily but but it does go to
to
your frame of mind there as as your your
designer's eye coming into play very
early as well as your eye as a patient
well i was i had figured out by that
time that
given there was so much wrong with these
places i was ultimately in eight
hospitals for rehab centers
it's not that they couldn't satisfy me
it's just that somebody would call and
to add the solution for you
and you know and they
they didn't and they don't and they
won't
and
i didn't realize that the time would be
set back
eight years with no stem cells but
too many people voted for the wrong guy
so
that's what happened and we
we we lost all that time which was
important
but anyway
so please vote
right
which means left
um
the
thing was that dr green got me got me
going i was last thing i said before
going into the apparent operating room
was
save my hands if it was without my hands
i can't draw
and he did and we're fast friends today
and
and i can use my hands you were actually
working in the in the hospitals while
you were there too i worked i worked all
the time and people
came
down to miami i have a small apartment
in miami
and people would come down there stay
there and come to with hospital
and we'd work all day which i could do
for my hospital bed
which i love doing
so
describe some of the problems with the
hospitals and rehab centers that you
that you saw
like just give me a couple of specifics
what what didn't work
well the best one of the best stories
is
is it happened in in kessler actually
and i don't take this out of the room
because they're good people
they're really good doctors there
designers they're not but the good
doctors
they had just
finished an addition to their
their center and
i was
i was in a position in my
rehab
where my my therapist said
michael if you
if you're able to throw on your clothes
in the morning
and
get into the wheelchair on your own
you can get out of this place
because we can't teach you any more
so i
piled up on my got a chair over before
getting into bed
i got a chair over next to the bed and
piled up all my clothes with my
underwear on the top
and i put my chair next to it
with a sliding board on the chair ready
to go in the morning
it took me about an hour
and
in my year i could hear my therapist
saying
it wouldn't take so long to tie your
shoes if you'd use velcro
and i told her that velcro was too ugly
i could
i couldn't do that
and um so
i got i got all my clothes on i was
feeling
very self-empowered
things were terrific
uh i got a grin from here to here
i got into getting into a chair by
yourself is it's hard and a little bit
scary when you're
on your own for the first time
but with a sliding board i did it
and uh
then i thought well
while i'll wait for
the doctor to do his rounds
i'll go into the bathroom
and shave and
comb my then hair and
brush my teeth
so i rolled into the bathroom
first thing i noticed was the
the mirror
started here and went up
it was for you standing
not for me now 99 of the people in this
rehab center are not in chairs
they don't walk
and they don't know they're not all
paralyzed a lot of them do have some
were quad some of them
are paraplegic some there are all kinds
of problems
anyway i
i
saw that the mirror was out of
reach so i
i reached for the cold water for my
toothbrush
and
and the faucet was way in the back of
the behind the sink
and i remember i said i can't bend over
much more than this
and uh so
that's that's my reach
so i couldn't reach
it was out of resoy
i thought well i won't get too close to
anybody today
and
then then it was hot water for shaving
same story out of reach
i thought well not a big problem there
i'll
have somebody from my office bring
my electric razor
and electric razor was
going to be plugged in somewhere and i
started by then i thought better find
out where to plug it in
and i looked around the plug was done
on the base of the
sill of the floor right before the floor
and you know where the plugs are down
when they're down below
about four inches up from the floor i
couldn't reach it
so all my self-empowerment
had gone to hell i mean it was all a
shock
but you
at this point had designed many many
buildings you know that there was an
architect's mind behind the space that
you were in the first thing that they
tell you in architecture school is a
form supposed to follow function no i
knew a specialist was behind it an
expert so this is what okay so even
worse
yeah i mean
i'm jumping ahead a little bit but did
you go look into what some of the
history behind why these places were
designed like this i mean that i can't i
can't believe there's somebody for your
expertise that must have been
exponentially more frustrating than just
as a person now what i did about it was
that just at that moment my
my doctor came for rounds
and i said i want your 10 minutes today
and he said what what can i do for you
and i said go out in the hall and get a
unused wheelchair and
there are thousands of them in the
hallway and bring it in here i want you
to do something
and you could imagine by asking me i
said go in the
bathroom and
see where the mirror is it's too high
as he did
this in the chair
and
then
i said can you reach the hot water
i said imitate me not somebody who's
ambulatory and
he said well then if i have to imitate
you i can't reach it so he went through
the whole thing and
he came back out and he said so what
and i said well
given the number of people that are in
chairs in this place
and you told me experts designed it and
you also told me a couple of days ago
that
the
you were building on a 40 million dollar
expansion
to kessler
i just want to know are using the same
experts
and he he said he was and i said look
dr k
architects aren't very smart
they're just not
we'd be doing we've been doing medicine
or something if we were smart i mean all
the talk just was earlier in the day
over my head and i can't do it i suspect
that's disingenuous but all right
anyway
with numbers i'm not so good but
these guys are not so good by the seat
of their pants
just the normal stuff that you'd expect
and so you have to call them on it so i
said
you're going to have to do something for
me he said what's that i said
you're going to have to hire and
a friend an architect friend to read
plans for you because i know you don't
or this wouldn't be happening
and i said you know buy him dinner do
something but get him to read the plans
and i said if you won't do that
build
build as the hospitality industry does
all the hotels no hotel in
america is built without a model room
build a model room and out in a
warehouse somewhere
don't spend a lot of money on just
wallboard cardboard i don't care
and see if everything is reachable along
all of that
just do it
and i said it'll cost you
five thousand dollars
and
not knowing whether it would or not it
could cost two thousand dollars
but but he said he would and of course
he didn't
and he built the new one with the
experts the stupid dumb architect
experts i'm an architect uh
and and he got what he paid for
okay so i tried
so now i'm on a quest
right so now you're now you're
sensitized to this yeah so
maybe we'll
look at some of the images that you
brought and we can talk about what came
out of this
um for you
we could do that
you might have the clicker so
i asked michael to bring some images of
what he's now gone on to do which is
design some
uh products
is that the right
term i should first say that you were a
heavy editor i had i had lots of i get
that a lot actually
had lots of stories to tell you and i
had people in wretched positions in
hospitals and and rooms that you really
ought to see in the bottom of over the
bed tables that that are growing moss
and you know stuff like that that
would have grossed you out but
but he said get rid of all that
because i'm going to be interviewing you
and just let me see some furniture now i
know how your doctors felt
this is
this is the over bed table that we
designed
um we found
working for striker
who um
they were a family they're in kalamazoo
michigan and
everything is made in america and so
it's going to be a little bit more
expensive than going to china with it we
had experiences before that with another
company which we would do this they
would send it to china it would come
back sort of sixty percent the way we
designed it
and the company would say good enough
we'd say no it's not my name's honor you
can't do this
so we had in our relationship with him
and so we found the striker striker
wanted to do it right
they had just designed an over the bed
table with
i think three shelves in it three
drawers two drawers on the top
so the drawers would sit yeah if you
were going if you were prone in bed the
door so you're in bed and the drawer
would open
here
right so and in the drawer was a mirror
that would flip up that way but you
couldn't get to it
so
um
there was this arms race that was going
on with over the bed tables which i
wasn't aware of and
and
so i i took theirs home with me
you can see my the size of my nurse she
couldn't move it across the room
it was it was just too heavy too
cumbersome
and
so
given that most nurses are female this
is this is going to be a problem
so i i put that put it on a diet and i
said look you've got to take all the
bells and whistles away
and make a
table that's really very functional i
want it to look good but i want it to
function and therefore
i knew that
things that you may not know that aren't
these are not earth shattering
but for instance when the tray comes
with your food on it
you've got to have a spot on your on
your over bed table free to put the tray
down
or
the the aid
takes it back outside and puts it
outside your door
to get cold or hot or whatever
so it has to be ready when you have to
be ready comes in
so i thought
can i do something to show it now
imagine in your mind
uh an old a bedside table with a lot of
garbage on it you know candy and flowers
and newspapers and spit cups and
toothpaste and all that stuff
and
some of that
goes up they think on the over the red
table
i thought if i could organize this
then i could also organize this i didn't
put it all on the over bed table
so
that little whitish area
backed by that enormous handle is for
your tissues and your cell phone
and
maybe the newspaper and the wooden part
is a place that you to keep clean
so that you can get your and then you
get to get your food and the nurse tells
you that
now the other thing that happens
i don't know whether you know
or not but
uh
990 000 people
die
every year
of diseases they catch in the hospital
more than all
all
automobile accidents and aids combined
by going to the hospital is a dangerous
event
there's uh there's something called cdf
which you don't attack your colon and
you don't want to know about that but
but look it up
there's
there's every reason to try to get the
cleaning crew
which they're interested in one we pay
them so little
that there's only one thing they're
interested and that's their break to
talk about what they did last night
so
i wanted to make the handles
and all the things that that they have
to clean
as big as possible you just do a fast
sweep instead of get into the way they
clean a chair is like this right it
makes
it makes usain bolt look slow i mean it
it's
incredible
so
i have a handle at both ends of this and
this thing really does slide
effortlessly across the floor
these aren't rocket science stuff of
course
the the paddle on the on the
back side there
on the right right there
is something that we had to correct
in the striker model that they were
selling
you put your hand into a slot it was
like the boca del verita
and you didn't know whether the hand was
gonna come out or not but
if you press down
on a lever in there
the table would go up and if you pulled
up the table would go down so very
intuitive you're saying very intuitive
so
we said can we change this they said no
you have to use the same mechanism we're
not retooling
so we turned it over
you turn you just turn the machinery up
the machine upside down
now this this lever is a paddle and just
goes up and down it's the simplest thing
in the world
so this this was the start of it and
they loved it and it went to
how
this stuff gets chosen to go into a
hospital
they take it to the hospital
the nurses the doctors all the
clinicians
the cleaning crew everybody takes a look
at it and votes
it's so democratic you can't possibly
win but that that but that also seems
like a part of the expression an ass
backwards way to collect data on usage
because that those aren't the users
those are the people who are maintaining
it but it's not
people who like you would have to use
the stuff right so we our job was made
easier by
an another thing that we designed which
i call r2d2
um
but here it is
and
i got them to make these two products at
the same time so
in these demonstrations to the hospital
they could see that one didn't have to
do all the work that they could be
shared
so what this guy does is first of all it
has a lever there you see the arrow that
goes up and down you can
the nurse can come in and she needs
horizontal surface everywhere
in the room she's looking for horizontal
surfaces do whatever she's brought in
put things on to put your lunch on your
tray on after you finish lunch
to write they have to write all the
notes for the doctors okay so that does
that and you can put this and my
my tray table
sort of kissing over the over the bed so
you can put your computer on one and
your food on the other all right the
thing that the nurses like the most is
that little blue bucket on the side
which is the waste basket
now this waste basket
they never can find the waste basket
after you interview
uh in 40 hospitals which is what we did
you find out that they couldn't find the
waste basket and that was the bane of
their existence well we could fix that
so we put it on the table
and and then we've got this little blue
bucket underneath
that you can put your valuables in we're
going to put a lock on that but it's got
the name of the hospital on and you can
take it home
for 75 cents you can take this thing
home so just carry all your stuff
instead of the brown bag that they give
you so
so uh
this thing again has the big handle and
another handle at the end so that
that the the
cleaning crew will will see that and and
clean it you know a lot of modern
furniture hands hides the handle
like it's a
no-no
it's undercut the the
vertical portion of a commode would be
cut
and
you pull it like that
can i ask you know instead i
did
this which is a big handle so they would
do it on them i'm sorry no it's fine i
mean the the the problems that you're
solving wouldn't even be apparent as
problems unless you
talk to all those folks in hospitals as
you did but i wonder if you would talk a
little bit about the the aesthetic
choices that you made also because you
mentioned that they also you said in the
last one that also looked good and you
know you're stylistically you were sort
of known you your work is sort of known
for being
for having some whimsy and some curves
and some fun about it you use colors no
quite the contrary but i just wonder as
you were thinking about these designs
what that balance was in your head as
you were of course i don't get rid of
those things that
i've been taught and i've done for 50
years but this has rounded corners for
instance
when somebody's in crisis mode in the
in the room
first thing that goes is things like
this in the over the bed table they're
all thrown practically thrown to the
wall
so that they can get a stretcher in and
get this person off and get them into
to
care
so all of these the furniture and the
walls are trying to be nice to each
other so i didn't make
sharp corners like this table
which doesn't have that problem
but here i do
so everything's been rounded
and
we have it comes in a very light wood
darker woods and so on
laminates
and
we're always surprised what people
choose
but but anyways
this is a chair you want to talk about
it yeah let's let's do the chair and
then and then that gives us enough time
we'll talk about this and then we can do
some questions
a few nights ago we went to dinner
and there was an
old guy there who must have been
i got to be careful he was
he was about 85 or 90.
he'd had a stroke
he was very feeble
and he walked to his table that he had
been led to
with his very frail wife
and he was offered a chair like the one
you're sitting in today
no arms
and
he wanted to sit down of course for
dinner
and he got in front of the chair
and you could see i was sitting we were
sitting next next to him
and i
he looked
at the chair
am i lined up there am i am i where i'm
supposed to be
yes i think so i'd like to try to help
you
oh no i don't want to pull you down
back and forth
the
waiters didn't know what to do
nobody knew
how to care for this fellow
there was no empathy if whatsoever
this was a good restaurant what do you
do well
if
they ask us tonight do you want to
do you want a handicapped room
i always like it i handicapped him no i
don't handicapped him
like that's the room without the mini
bar
this is
presumably the room with a railing in
the bathroom right so i can find my way
to the can
so
i thought of this chair that we had
designed for stryker
which we call the stand assist chair
now this is really for the
the hospital room
but
i mean you look at the handles
look how far out in front they are
think of my old friend
who's trying to set down the man with a
stroke he would have put his hands
here first
scooted back
and then lowered himself down using his
arms
but he didn't have
arms on his chair
it was they were designed out
all right
and they're flared so that once you're
in the chair you have room to move your
arms around
so here's somebody
who's sitting in the chair
and pulling himself forward
and then doing something tonight when
you get ready for bed
sit on the edge of your bed and put your
nose over your toes
and then lift yourself up not with the
arms just nose over toes and lift
yourself up see what happens see where
the strength of your body is it's not in
your stomach it's in your torso
and then by the time he gets to the end
there he is he's not only pulled himself
forward but he's done his nose over toes
and he stood up now read it like the old
man in the restaurant read it backwards
so there he's doing this
and then he's bending his knees
which he can still do
and down he goes softly so we call this
chairs stand assist
now you ask about aesthetics is this the
most beautiful chair i can make
this is the most beautiful chair i can
make with this
characteristic
i've done a low version like your couch
by the way nobody in back can see you
i don't know what you meant
but jay knows that everybody has to
stand
try to sit up a little straighter
anyway
sorry doctor
we'll just do one more thing and then
and then we'll take some questions from
you folks but
what that what that chair says to me um
as somebody who spent a long time in
ikea trying to find a chair with arms
for my braille grandmother and couldn't
find one is that is that these pieces
have a market outside just hospitals and
healthcare is the market in healthcare
big enough to make them
worth designing and building do you see
them going to be sold
in furniture stores or in cares and
places where people go to buy stuff for
healthcare like i would for my
grandmother
who gets access to these they've been on
the market for about a year
and they're in 20 hospitals
and when you're in 20 hospitals that
means 300 or 400 a piece for each
hospital
so stryker is absolutely delighted and
the more pieces we have like here are
four pieces
with the stool five
the more they have to choose from for
the room
right so much so that they're now
collecting these pieces putting them in
rooms and say michael graves designed
this hospital
but a nice segue to questions from the
audience um so we'll there are you know
the drill already there are mics that
are going to come around and we'll do
this for a few minutes does anybody have
a
question or thought we'll put an arm up
i see one here and maybe you guys in the
back can see
better than i can
sorry the long mic distance there's the
the leed certification program for sort
of green building i'm wondering if you
see something in as far as the built
environment and the public health of
population help for designing an
environment for health or for easier
access sort of mild after leader for
something else you tell of a hospital or
building was actually suitable for not
just you and your elderly parents but
you know as we age as where health
changes it gets to be a lot easier to
have these sorts of you know
advancements in the built environment
not just in real medical devices okay
can i i'll just add to that too why does
an ada cover some of this americans
disability it seems like would cover
because it's a very light law
it doesn't go far enough so could there
be an increase could there be a version
of lead these are two very different
questions
you can make a very ugly hospital and it
can be leed certified it could be lead
platinum
the hospital wouldn't know any different
it could be a dog
you could also design a beautiful
hospital make it leap out down platinum
or no lead at all right
and none of those things would have
anything necessarily with how patients
would very little to do with the kind of
stuff that i'm talking about right but
they don't but they don't conflict with
each other so you can do both of them at
the same time if you're if you're a
smart architect could there could there
be a regulatory or i guess not
regulators leave's not regulatory lee
doesn't have those kind of teeth but a
way to say like
right now right so if you're but but i
mean could you imagine a way to put
together a set of standards that then
hospitals could without without
necessarily having to say well we were
designed by michael graves but instead
to say we were think of the political
problems yes you could do that
but if you said it you have to adhere by
to these issues
john boehner would go not sure it'd have
to be it'd have to be voluntary like
yeah right
what else
right there
thank you
i'm wondering if in your stay in the
hospital or since you've
considered any ways to improve the
lighting
management the sound management and the
air quality management in hospitals
yeah all the furniture that we're
designing for instance has
something called an easy glide foot
i didn't talk about it but
when you're in the hospital and you're
in your room
and somebody has a crisis up above
and they start throwing furniture around
you hear everything and it might be four
o'clock in the morning
so the question is good what can you do
about that you can make what you do as
quiet as you can the rest is
construction
how can you baffle the sound from one to
the other you know there's only one way
to do it and that's with money
and you've got to have the money to do
it uh
and so you have to lobby for that
because it is it is crucial that we get
it right
the idea of light and all that we are
tackling now we're designing
a headboard
which has the light in it and
and all the gases and all the
electricity that you need
and to try to add that to the room we
decided i decided that since i was
a designer an architect and a patient
i'd had the credentials to do this so i
was going to
start with the
the patient room and make it the best i
could and then go
to there from from there to the public
spaces and then the hospital itself it
hasn't happened quite that way we're
doing a couple of hospitals now so
we get to do the whole package so you go
from just from furniture in a room to
the systems
that need them
right there
i had a light in one of the hospitals
that i turned on with a string
you had to the job we're not in uganda
with a string yeah and i broke it
and i couldn't get the nurse to come
turn it out so i could go to sleep and
all the other things that you're talking
about are
also cues for the uh the overall
unpleasant hospital experience anybody
who spend any time in hospital these are
all small things that are the things
that trigger you're like wow hospitals
suck right like
individually they aggregate into an
unpleasant experience sorry i'm taking
your time i'm dr bob walker i'm from
germany i work for the us army and
the follow-on question there is is again
when we our patients have come up from
the theater the last time they open her
eyes are in a striker vehicle the next
minute they open their eyes are in an
icu with lots of noise and beeping
do you find that hospitals are designed
for us the doctor
versus you the patient and that can be
noise every alarm that goes off is for
me the doctor the nurse and very rarely
is it designed for the patient and until
you're actually a patient maybe you
don't
you know really come to realize that so
um and
i was wondering part of your interest
now was there an interest before you
were injured or had this illness
or
maybe this was you know part of the ways
god telling you hey there's a mission
for you after you have this illness to
design this so
um that's one question the other
question that i had as a follow-on as
that fits with the conference a little
bit
as a healthcare provider actually found
answers on pinterest it's an amazing
source of information we talked about
patient falls a little while ago and i
last week i went on pinterest and said
patient falls and it opened the question
to the world that everyone's grappling
with this and they put cool pictures of
ideas that they've had so as a designer
i wonder if you ever look at
crowdsourcing ideas and then taking
ideas and designing them into a patient
experience type of
design you know what pinterest is it's i
have it
right so i mean i guess that's it's a
good question about the ideas too but it
but also the that i have never dialed in
patient falls so i'll do that
well your first question is interesting
i
went ten days ago or two weeks ago i was
at
madison x
and
i talked to a doctor at dinner
for the whole dinner i found him
fascinating i kept him going
he was doing all the talking i loved it
i could just i could just listen now
you're making me feel bad again no no
and so
it's okay
um
and he said
in med school we're told
that we're first we're told that it's
it's doctor-centered
where everything is for us
and not for the patient
and what you're bringing to us
is the opposite
and so
what happens then i'm not sure sure but
evidently if it's true and i'm not
saying it is true
if if it's true that
that it's that it's not patient centered
then
we
the medical schools have to do something
about it because that's where it starts
i can think of one example
where they
redesigned a space in hospitals to make
them more patient centered which was in
um neonatal intensive care units right
where the lights and sounds got turned
down and then outside the hospital some
of the some of the light and sound some
of the environmental cues that you've
been asking about what um they did on
airplanes and airplane cabins the design
of an airplane is totally different than
it was 20 years ago for those very same
reasons
indirect lighting um different colors of
lighting
the space look
the space changed a bit so there are
other there are designers who've thought
of these
issues just never in the places that you
thought of them well they're just not in
the hospital yeah um think about the
airplanes i mean what's happening now i
mean
business class is a sleeper now to go to
europe terrific
you know
and
there there are there are hospitals that
are are still building curbs
outside the shower room
and you can't get in
and
you say make a horse island drain
they'll say we haven't heard of that
and wait wait neither have i what's that
drain
a horizontal drain oh sorry horizontal
okay yeah yeah uh not dream sorry i've
panicked somebody thought i didn't know
what the word horizontal meant i i did i
just didn't hear him sorry
horizontal drain
uh instead of a central drain so i can
get my
my
one of the pictures i
didn't bring
look look up here
is my bathroom which i changed before i
could come come home
so that i could get you have to get into
a shower chair to shower
if you're in my situation
a shower chair is aluminum this one is
knob this is steel
and so
so to get into a shower chair and to get
the shower chair under the shower
you have to get over
a four-inch curb in most hotels and in
most
in most
hospitals
it's madness
and that goes on and on and on
what else
in the back there please and then we'll
then we'll go right here
the previous question uh
uh asked also related to something that
was kind of personal
you went through a catastrophic event
and a lot of people who go through
catastrophic events decide to shrink up
and go into a hole
become bitter angry whatever you decided
to use this catastrophic event to
benefit the world something transcending
you did things that many many other
people wouldn't have done
and uh
quite honestly that's what i'm most
impressed about this entire last hour
what you've done as a result of this
catastrophe and i guess i'm just
wondering whether there's a particular
event or something about your character
that
decided to move forward in this yes
i was born in the midwest
and
i'm
i'm a very positive person when once i
was
paralyzed i said
okay now when am i going to get better
i really thought i was going to get
better
when i got the little sticker to go or
the little flag to go on the rear view
mirror that says i can park
closer to the grocery store
it said permanent
as the first that's the only time
anybody told me that it was prominent
my doctor had he kept saying four years
four years six years six years
but um
i know i've got too much energy to
to
shrink and i
i want to solve
what i can of this problem i only would
get it started but if i get some sort of
movement started here
along with all that's been happening
think of the
the
medical conferences in the last year
there
i've spoken at eight or ten of them and
and uh
it's the best thing that's happened to
us something's afoot here and that that
is going to change all of this
and it's going to get to those experts
in hospital design just like it is going
to get to all the people are using
numbers and data and all that one last
one i promise would go really fast
because everybody's getting antsy i can
tell
there was one on this side right there
sort of closer to me
um so i think it's really helpful when a
parent can stay overnight with a child
in the hospital or a spouse or loved one
and what i've seen is remarkably
uncomfortable chairs that turn into beds
or window seats that are impossible to
sleep on by any chance has your group
turned its attention
to helping patients feel comfortable by
having someone stay with them
i had
on
the slides a
slide that came up for a while right at
the end we didn't talk about it a chair
that is a transfer chair it it
let's see it's down in the lower left
there
and it if you're going to have an mri in
the hospital this isn't your question
but it's close
if you're going to have an mri or cat
scan or an x-ray
you have to get from your bed to a chair
you have to be taken down you can't get
in one of those black chairs that
was done in 1933
but unorderly takes you down to
the laboratory you might wait for an
hour
45 minutes to an hour
and for a spinal patient like myself
that's that's crisis time you really
need more comfort than that so we
designed this transfer chair that is
just coming off those striker lines now
and it's a huge hit and we're very
pleased with
with that but then what we have we have
to make a deal with another company
a furniture company to do
the bed that turns into the couch or
turns into the or the couch that turns
into the bad part of me
there's one like that in a new hospital
in princeton except when you open it it
hits the patient bed
i mean
so you know
you can work those things out you don't
even have to build i won't tell my
doctor
and kessler you don't even have to build
the
model room
but you can do that by drawings and
measuring
but but uh
that's a very easy thing to do it's done
there are a lot of them on the market
they're not very attractive but there
are a lot of them on the market
michael graves thank you for talking to
us about that